여러분들 건물을 사드리겠습니다 강남구
지역에 50억 미만의 건물을 제가
직접 도와드리면서 건물을 매입해
[음악]
드리겠습니다 아네 드디어 강남
프로젝트에 어 건물을
[음악]
매입하셨으면 오늘 정 대략
한네 안녕하세요 빌사남 있니다 한
2년 정도 된 거 같은데 저희가
강남빌딩 메이 프로젝트 1로 당첨자분
아마 마지막 촬영 영상이 한 2년
정도 된 거 같습니다 지금 저희가
매입한게 이제 곧 중공을 좀 앞두고
있거든요 당첨자분 좀 모셔서 간단하게
인터뷰를 진행하도록 하겠습니다
안녕하세요네
안녕하세요 진짜 한 2년 됐죠 매이
반기네 2년 정도 된 거 같아요
시간이 굉장히 좀 빨리 되는데 어
저희가 그동안 진짜 매입 하는데도
오래 걸렸고 그리고 이제 신축하지 한
상태여서 제가 봤을 때는 거의 한 3
4년은 된 거 같아요 처음 뵙고 한
진짜 한 3년 4년 정도 그렇게 좀
시간이 좀 오래 걸렸는데 좀 지금
혹시 좀 심정이 어떠신지네 지금
심정 솔직한 말로는 이제 아무래도
요즘에 전체적으로 경기가 좋지는 않다
보니까 아 네네네 좀 이제 이제 임대
매매 이런게 조금 빨리 잘 진행됐으면
하는 바람이고 비게 해체한 걸 보니까
되게 좀 기분도 좋고 아 그런 기분도
있고네네 그죠 그러니까 맨날 이제
PC 그만 이제 이미지로만 보다가
진짜 이제 실물로 보인 거거든요 저도
그 기분을 알아요 가해가 좀 새롭고
맨날 가서 보게 되더라고 어 아무래도
이게 매입할 때 저희가 진짜 좀
힘들었잖아요 매입할 때 많이 놓치기도
하고 진짜 많이 검토했던 거 같아요
물건들은 딱 타이밍 좋게음 좀 매입을
했는데 좀 매입할 때 기분이 좀
어떠셨는지 좀 궁금합니다 매입할 때
기분 그때 영상에서도 한번 말씀드렸던
거 같은데 그냥 저 물건 보지도 않고
그냥 아 님이 괜찮은 거 같다라고
하셔 가지고 제일 큰 자산을 취득하는
거였다 보니까 제 입장에서는 되게 좀
두려움도 있었었는데 그냥
질러버렸습니다 아 질러 그때 아마
저도 기억에 남는게 점심 먹고 나서
이제이 매물이 나온 거예요 그래서 딱
확인하고 나서 바로 제가 아마 2시쯤
엔가 전화해서 5시에 나오시라고 바로
이제 계약했던 어 그런 기억이 좀
있습니다 그 저는 이거 봤을 때이
땅이 마음에 들었던게 북향 땅이었고
뒤에 약간 경사가 있어서 한 계층을
인정받을 수 있는 그런 땅이었어요 딱
그걸 보자마자 짓기에는 너무 좋은
땅이다라고 해가지고 바로 전화를
했었던 그런 기억이 있습니다 신축하면
10년 늙는다는 막 얘기 많잖아요네네
저도 많이 들었던 말이었어 혹시
신축하면서 좀 어려웠던 점이
있으실까요 저 진짜 이거 사실
어려웠던 점은 딱히 없었던 거 같아요
저 아 그래요 이제 감리하는 팀장
님께서도 잘해 주시고 해서 크게
어려웠던 점은 없는 거 같아요 김준석
소장님한테 설계도 하셨고 그다음에
저희가 건설사 통해서 이제 건물
신축하지 한 거여서 책임감 있게
맡아서 했던 거 같습니다 그리고 건물
중에 자랑할 만한 좀 그런 공간이
있을까요 어 아무래도 이제 성큰 부분
지하층 있데 이제 성큰 부분이 있어서
조금 개방감이 있고 음 그리고 마지막
층도 이제 고가 좀 높다 보니까 좀
시원해 보이고 이런 부분이 제일 좋은
거 같아요 저 사실 땅이 크진
않잖아요 예 크진 않지만 지하의 그
성큰 공간을 만들어서 좀 이렇게
최강이라는 이런게 되게 잘 들어오고
그리고 이제 마지막 옥상에는 층고가
진짜 높고 창도 좀 크게 나 있어서
뭐 제가 봤을 때는 진짜 뭐 회의실이
좀 CEO 분이 좀 쓸 만한 그런
방으로 쓰기 너무 좋은 거 같아요
생각하셨을 때 뭔가 건물 투자의
장단점이 꽃잠이 있을까요 다른 이제
주식이라 그지 요즘에 또 많이 하는
코인 이런 경우에는 아무래도 계속
보게 되고 많이 시간에 얽매이게 되는
거 같은데 그런 자산들에 비해서는 좀
안전 자산이다 보니까 부분하고 좀
기다릴 수 있지 않나 이런 장점이
있는 거 같아요 그 레버리지 이런
부분도 물론 장점이 될 수 있고 그럼
단점은 혹시 뭐가 있을까 단점 팔 수
있을 때 이제 바로 팔기는 조금
어려울 수 있다 이런 너무 반한
얘기인 거 같긴 한데 그런 거 아
근데 말씀하신게 되게 정확한게 저는
빌딩 투자할 때 가장 중요하게
생각하는게 환금성이 생각하거든요
그니까 언제든지 시장에 내놨을 때
팔려야 진짜 투자 가치가 있는 건데
빌딩은 아무래도 환금성이 좀 많이
떨어져요 예 아무래도 투자할 때 좀
이렇게 환금성이 높은 지역에 사는게
되게 중요하고 그리고 아까 앞서
설명해 주셨던게 사실 코인이나 주식은
진짜 매일 보면 좀 피해지 근데
건물은 어찌됐든 환금성이 떨어지긴
하지만 그래도 뭐 가치가 갑자기 뭐
이게 막 몇 10% 떨어지는 것도
아니고 약간 강제 장투 이런 느낌도
있는 거
같아 그리고 약간 또 현금 가지고
있으면 계속 뭐 어디서 쓰거든요
조금조금씩 막 사라지고 그러는데
빌딩은 아무래도 그게 좀 없다 보니까
장투 개념으로 좀 가지고 있기는 뭐
제가 봐도 그게 장점인 거 같긴
합니다 그리고 좀 민감한 질문이긴
한데 투자실
투자금는 대략 한 25억 내외 정도
아 25억 2억 10억 정도 내외인
거 같아요 이제 전부 다 앞에서 이제
세금이라는 이런 부분 앞에서 정도 된
거 같아요 정리를 해보자면 한 매입은
한 50억 원대 매입을 했고 신축하는
비용 뭐 이렇게 뭐 이거 세금 이런
거 저런 거 다 합치면 제가 봤을 때
거의 한 70억 한 초중반 이제이자
비용 이런 거까지 다 하면은 한
70억 중반 정도 70억 중반인데
실제로는 현금이 한 25억 정도네
들어간 상태입니다 그리고 저희가 지금
임대 진행 하고 있는게 2,700만
원의지 진행 중인 걸로네 일단은 뭐
이렇게 보시면 될 거 같습니다 그래서
많은 분들이 실투 자금을 되게 좀
궁금해 하세요 지금 신축비 아지 한
75억짜리 프로젝트를 한다라고 하면은
현금이 한 20억 중반에서 뭐 많게
30억까지 된다라고 생각하시면 될 거
같습니다 마지막으로 소감 같은 거 한
말씀해 주시면 좋을 것 같습니다 소감
사실 이제 건축 행이라는게 쉽게 해볼
수 있는 경험은 아니잖아요 인들이
그런 부분에 있어서 참 좋 경험한 거
같고 재밌는 부분도 있었었고 아
임대라 이런 부분 좀 잘 됐으면
좋겠다 거 바람고 이제 아마 중공이
며칠 안 남았어요 비계를 철거한지가
그렇게 오래되진 않았는데 이제 비계
철거한 시점부터 이제 임대를 진행을
하고 있습니다 저희가 좀 최대한 빨리
임대를 맞춰서 좀 정상적으로 돌아갈
수 있게 만드는게 저의 목표이기도
하고 믿고
있습니다 뭐 사실 요즘에 임대 상황이
그 좋지 않은데 그래도 지금이 건
컨디션이랑 그렇게 가격을 봤을 때는
그렇게 높은 건 아니어서네 그래서
제가 봤을 때는 조금 기다리면 좀
마칠 수 있지 않을까네 이렇게 예상을
합니다 그래서 저희가 일단은 임대
맞추고 좀 추 상황까지도 좀 영상에
담을 수 있으면은 같이 좀 추가적으로
담도록 하겠습니다 쉽지 않았어요 쉽지
않았고 시간도 오래 걸렸지만 그만큼
결과가 좋게 나왔습니다 예 나오고
지금 임대까지 좀 치면은 어 저도
마음이 너무 편할 것 같아서 강남
빌딩 메이 프로젝트를 계속 지켜봐
주시면 좋을 것 같고요 그래서 오늘
영상은 여기까지 하고요 어 다음
시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다 감사합니다
감사합니다